[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
day two
ukrainian countryside
uh started really nice
i don't know four o'clock in the morning
and then the religious music started
playing
and i opened up the door and looked into
the living room and the family was
standing there
praying
so
i jumped in
closed my
eyes and put my hands together
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
a guy came by today
a neighbor
and he had like this uh
little metal thing in his hand
and it was just sort of spinning around
and
when it would get to a right the right
point
it would sort of stop
and what they're looking to do is find
where to dig the well
we have to
use buckets
in the bathtub and there's no drain in
the bathtub so we have to like buck it
in the bathtub and then
extract the water
[Music]
[Laughter]
family's fantastic wonderful beautiful
people beautiful beautiful people really
and cool valerie sat me down
next to the computer
and he played this video or a couple
videos of uh blown out apartments
and then he told me that was
the building that they lived in
today was stunning with um alisa
she was correcting my pronunciation in
russians
[Music]
[Music]
yeah she's such a little ray of sunshine
such a beautiful
human being
and then mark came up the little guy
he's he's only two but he's got a really
bubbly personality and max max really
opened up today and he got behind the
camera a little was shooting some stuff
and i want to get him on this project to
actually shoot some
some footage because he
first impressions of valeri are this you
know he's got this bad boy look to him
with the tattoos but it takes very
little time around him
to feel the genuine
and warm side of this
well that's when the frog hunting
process started so we walked
down this dirt
on this pathway down to the river it's a
real
narrow river
valeria was hilarious i mean he was out
there like a hunter like a true
primitive man he had his
he had his little stick and his his net
and he was like he assumed the position
of like this hunter gatherer guy and
he's good like he got up
and um
killed these frogs and then smacked them
on the rocks
and yeah it can be looked at as cruel
but
i don't know we ate the food like
within an hour afterwards
super
um
and that was my first time
having frog legs and they were amazing
really exceptional
yes
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
yet
oh
[Music]
he's
got an open heart he's a very loving
father
and you can tell that his family is
absolutely everything to him
[Music]
[Laughter]
was getting ready for a tattoo
so there's this kid in here that what he
said on it sits something on his fist
like
like [ __ ] off or something like that
forget and uh
he worked on valet for a while
[Music]
is
during the prayer session this morning a
new guy walked in
and his name is a leg
and he is the well digger
when they said they were going to dig a
well i was
thinking you know bring a machine in and
you know drill out a well i had no idea
what we were talking about
savonia
me buddha
shovel by shovel we're digging this well
until
we actually hit water
buchita
mud
[Music]
yellow blue
[Music]
nice guy
big smile
real soft gentle
humble guy i enjoyed digging with him
today even though i have to say he did
most of the work
elisa
[Music]
today was uh
very interesting day
and what is it my third day out here in
the countryside
yeah feels like i've been here much
longer
starting to feel this place
it hasn't taken me long to really
warm up to fellaini
and we do simple things we go to
a berry tree and eat berries together or
walk to a lake
laugh a lot
i mean i don't understand everything
he's saying
probably more like 40 percent
but it really doesn't matter
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah it's just this exotic
place
not exotic like the tropics of uh
you know southeast asia
but exotic in the sense that it's
totally it's totally a different reality
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it feels
this this fish out of water
ah
you know julia who's my friend and i was
also doing the translation for this
video she gave this i mean i definitely
feel like this here
[Music]
well
that was about it today
this is pure simplicity pure beauty
pure connectivity between the family
between the family and nature
wow
[Music]
tomorrow's another adventure i don't
know where we're going we're going
somewhere at 8 30 and i couldn't really
understand what they were saying
so that's sort of my story here i can't
really understand
much of what's going on so
that's it for now
until tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you